though it was something of a box-office
disappointment when it first hit
theaters in 1997 looper sounds
whacked-out sci-fi epic The Fifth
Element has since become a cult classic
thanks to gonzo visuals and quirky
performances from stars Bruce Willis
Milla Jovovich and Chris Tucker
but despite the film's popularity
there's never been a follow-up here's a
look at some of the reasons why the
Fifth Element never got a sequel it
wasn't a huge hit The Fifth Element
didn't fare particularly well during its
theatrical release in the United States
which was a problem because at the time
the movies 90 million dollar plus price
tag made it the most expensive film ever
produced outside of Hollywood while the
film would go on to break some
international box office records by
pulling in two hundred and sixty three
million dollars worldwide it scored just
63 million dollars of that take from US
theaters which is probably a big reason
an equally expensive sequel wasn't quick
to get the green light the story was
complete vobis on originally envisioned
The Fifth Element as part of a trilogy
the story of main characters Corbin and
Lilu actually feels pretty complete at
the end of the film
he's rediscovered his vigor for life
she's found a reason to want to save the
earth the pair have found love together
and in the process they've literally
brought peace to the galaxy sure Besson
could probably find a clever way to
shake these two out of their well-earned
happiness at this point though it might
feel more like a desperate cash grab
especially considering Willis is now in
his mid 60's much as fans would like to
see more nobody wants to see the fifth
elements legacy tarnished by an
unnecessary second act
[Music]
very very sad off-screen drama
one of the biggest complicating factors
when it comes to a sequel is the
off-screen drama between Busan and yoga
vich during filming of The Fifth Element
the two became romantically involved and
got married not long after the film's
premiere it didn't last though as their
relationship fell apart on the set of
their 1999 collaboration the messenger
the story of Joan of Arc the film
flopped and the couple divorced the same
year still anything's possible
according to yoga vich their
relationship worked a lot better on set
than off set she told the Scottish Daily
Record if we could make movies to 365
days a year we would still be together
Luke and I have this unique creative
connection we did get married but we're
not together anymore in that sort of
particular context we're best friends
apart from being together or not he
loves me I love him for sans enigmatic
career when it comes to sequels you
should always strike while the iron's
hot but after the mess that was the
messenger the story of Joan of Arc and
the dissolution of his marriage to yoga
vich the Sun went the other direction
stepping away from directing entirely
for six years to focus on writing
instead that break may have squandered
any momentum for a Fifth Element sequel
but that's par for the course for Besson
who doesn't seem to be interested in
revisiting his past as a director other
than a couple of animated films beside
has never directed a sequel even passing
the reins of the proposed follow-up to
his 2014 hit Lucy it seems it would have
to take something pretty special to
convince him to return to the world of
the fifth element special effect
frustrations when the fifth element
arrived in theaters it was regarded as a
bona fide special-effects bonanza
but according to Masson the special
effects in the fifth element were
frustrating to work with because the
technology didn't exist yet to truly
fulfill his vision perhaps if the
effects had existed at the time the Sun
would have moved forward with the rest
of the trilogy but now that the
technology does finally exist he seems
to have moved on to other projects
speaking of which a spiritual sequel
dobersen has suggested in interviews
that he might be open to filming other
stories set in the same universe as the
fifth element for the last decade most
of his energy seems to have been turned
towards his big screen adaptation of the
long-running French comic book series
valerian and the city of a thousand
planets
filled with mind-blowing imagery only
made possible by advances in effects
over the past 20 years valerian and the
city of a thousand planets unfortunately
failed to launch at the box-office
taking in just two hundred and twenty
five million dollars worldwide against a
huge 177 million dollar budget since the
film underperformed the future of the
franchise is up in the air but
considering Besson was reportedly
planning to break his own rule against
sequels by turning Valyrian into a
trilogy it seems as though his heart
just isn't in the Fifth Element anymore
Never Say Never
though there's an argument to be made
that it's often better to leave your
fanbase wanting more but science still
shows a lot of affection for the world
of the fifth element and that would seem
to leave the door open if only slightly
for a sequel
even if Corbin and Lulu aren't at the
center of the story we'd still love to
see where the sign might take things
next just as long as it isn't a Ruby
rhod origin story all due respect to
Besson and Chris Tucker but some
characters are just more fun in small
doses thanks for watching click the
looper icon to subscribe to our YouTube
channel plus check out all these cool
stuff we know you love to
[Music]